can you believe donald trump won't
disavow
white supremacists it's shocking it was
so easy
and he just couldn't do it he just
refused in case
you missed the debate this is the
biggest story from that whole debate the
other night
here is just a little taste of president
trump
i don't even i don't even want to play
it here is just a little taste of
president trump that racist
refusing to condemn white supremacists
racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name
are criminals and thugs including the
kkk
neo-nazis white supremacists and
other hate groups that are repugnant to
everything
we hold dear as americans and you had
people
and i'm not talking about the neo-nazis
and the white nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
we are a nation
founded on the truth that all of us
are created equal we are equal in the
eyes of our creator
we are equal under the law and we are
equal
under our constitution
those who spread violence in the name of
bigotry
strike at the very core of america how
many times do i have to reject
i've rejected david duke rejected david
duke
i've rejected the kkk the klu klux klan
from the time i'm five years old i
rejected them now
i have been asked this question so many
times i have rejected it so many times
oh wait a minute sorry my mistake i
guess he's condemned white supremacy and
racism
a zillion times huh i guess the media is
just lying about it i wonder what else
they're lying about
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
gosh those people those editors at the
news organizations they might need to
hire some new people because it looks
like
their reporters are lying just lying
right through their teeth about the
president
and hiring can be very very difficult
that's why
i always prefer to use ziprecruiter you
see
zip recruiter does not depend on
candidates finding
you ziprecruiter goes out finds the
candidates
for you zip recruiters technology
identifies people with the right
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply which
is why you should try ziprecruiter for
free
at ziprecruiter.com slash knowles knwes
that is how monica found lamont jenkins
she said that zip recruiter sent
lamont's profile to her
around five minutes after she posted her
job because he was such a great match
for the role
through ziprecruiter monica's company
has hired everyone from accountants
to project managers to field scientists
but monica's
not the only employer who loves
ziprecruiter
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter
get a quality candidate within what the
first month the first week no
the first day see for yourself as if
recruiter makes hiring faster and easier
try it now for free that is for free
totally zip zilch not a free
at ziprecruiter.com slash knowles that
is
ziprecruiter.com cano wlas
ziprecruiter.com
knowles so my favorite comment from
yesterday from sean murphy
democrats say a 19 year old who
committed double murder
should not be executed because his brain
isn't fully formed
democrats also say 16 year olds should
vote i know this is the big
issue this is there's always this
contradiction here with the democrats
which is the democrats focus on consent
consent consent right so
that's the only moral standard they
haven't consent and yet
they're trying to extend consent over
over voting
over sexual matters over gen gender
right gender identity
to people who are below the age of
consent
i mean to even be on the voting sure
they're saying a 25 year old 40 year old
can't be executed for murder because
when he was 19 his brain wasn't formed
but a 16 year old can vote and the
five-year-old can choose his own sex
doesn't make a lot of sense lots of
false
information going around notably
on this issue of race where it's the
same old trick they use against every
republican that used it against donald
trump
even though he's condemned white
supremacy a zillion times including in
the debate but then i guess
what he had some issue where he didn't
then
totally condemn this one group that
we're being told as a white supremacist
group
joe biden's already got an attack ad out
about it are you willing
tonight to condemn white supremacists
and militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to specifically
do it i would say almost everything i
see
is from the left wing not from the right
what are you what are you doing what are
you saying
i'm willing to do anything i want to see
people do it sir say it
do it say it you want to call him what
do you want to call him give me your
name give me a surprise
stand back and stand by
[Applause]
the proud boys the white supremacists do
you know i mean the proud boys what
they're
they're the successor organization to
the ku klux klan right they're
a bunch of skinhead neo-nazi white
supremacists right
right that's what i've been told by the
mainstream media aren't they it turns
out they're not
it turns out they're not and you know
how i figured that out
a simple google search and then the
first article that comes up is usa today
so i click on usa today
they're left wing but they're a little
more balanced obviously in the new york
times or something like that
and i see right there at the top that
the proud boys have ties to white
supremacy okay well
all right they're white supremacists
that's it right but luckily i didn't
stop there
luckily i read two paragraphs down
where i found a fact that was very
confusing to me
apparently the leader of the proud boys
is a guy named
enrique torrio and enrique torrio
is an afro-cuban it's a black cuban
and then enrique torrio the afro-cuban
leader of the alleged white supremacist
group
has come out and said that there are
quote long-standing regulations
prohibiting racist white supremacist
or violent activity
this according to the group's lawyer
ronald coleman he's also a spokesman it
turns out for the proud voice
uh tario the leader the afro-cuban
leader says through coleman quote
we do not care what color you are or
what your background is if you love
america we consider you
a brother and then the group condemned
racism
fascism communism and socialism
so okay we got the white supremacist bad
boys
run by an afro-cuban condemning racism
fascism communism and socialism
then you've got the left then you've got
the left blm
in particular blm using explicitly
racist language
and forget condemning communism and
socialism openly embracing it
the leader of blm went on television
patrice colors and said we are trained
marxists
once again i should have known
the left is accusing the right of the
very thing that the left is doing and
the thing that the right is not doing
look around the country at the
the destruction the violence the looting
the arson
the statues toppling down is that being
done by white supremacists i don't think
so
i don't see show me show me them i don't
see that i see antifa
no a lot of those guys are white but i
don't think they're white supremacists i
think they're anarchists and communists
i think they're leftists
a lot of it's being done by blm i don't
think those guys are white supremacists
all of that is being done with the
encouragement of elected democrats
it's just a lie it's just another lie
now i i had a hunch about this because i
remember i followed the proud boys a
little bit i don't really know the group
very well but i remember gavin mcginnis
founded it gavin mcginnis a comedian he
is a little edgy right he gets in
trouble i think i don't know i
only know him a little bit but i've
never known gavin to be a white
supremacist
and gavin's not running it anymore it's
this other fellow toriel
and then i i i thought because i've i've
seen it at different you know big
political rallies and there's a left
there and the right there
i have seen some proud boys and the
thing that's a little weird when you see
the proud boys if you're told they're
white supremacists is
you see a lot of black proud boys and
you see a lot of hispanic proud boys
and then it turns out their leader is an
afro-cuban guy
just another lie speaking of hispanic
guys by the way
i think i know why the left is pushing
this lie because there was a poll
that came out after the debate this was
a poll done
by telemundo so for a spanish-speaking
audience
two-thirds of the telemundo audience
that was watching that debate between
donald trump and joe biden two-thirds
thought trump won the debate
now my view of this was that that was
because these people didn't speak
english
so they were they're just looking at
body language or something like that
but i think that's actually a little
unfair i don't think anybody won the
debate i think it was more or less a
draw
i thought trump scored better points in
terms of the issues
but because chris wallace kept bailing
out joe biden i didn't think it was such
a clear win
but the spanish-speaking audience
thought that
only 34 of the telemundo audience
thought that joe biden beat donald trump
that's pretty interesting i don't know
what that means in terms of
how they were watching the debate but i
do know what it means in terms of how
democrats are watching that poll
democrats are very afraid that president
trump is making
some inroads with hispanic voters
possibly even black voters
two groups that the democrats rely on
don't forget donald trump doesn't
need to win a majority of these groups
he's just got to make inroads
to crack the left's monopoly
and it looks as though he might be doing
this the left has never understood how
they thought when donald trump came down
that escalator in 2015 and said we're
going to end illegal immigration
because drug cartels are sending rapists
and murderers across our border and
we're not going to do that and some
people are probably
good people but but there are a lot of
bad people crossing the border they said
oh yeah he's a racist
did you see that hispanic americans he's
a racist
he's saying that drug cartels are
sending rapists and murders and then a
lot of hispanic americans turned to them
and said
he's right he's right there obviously
they're doing that and we
we don't support rapists and murderers
just because of what our skin color or
something or the language we speak
how dare you say that how dare you do
that
and uh this is the same issue that's
gone on as the democrats have taken the
black vote for
for granted president trump goes out he
makes a pitch he says what have you got
to lose
what have you got to lose well it seems
that that is making some inroads will
that translate in november
i don't know but the democrats are
certainly
going to continue to try to gin up those
racial tensions
what they're now saying is that debates
themselves this is how i know they think
president trump did fairly well at the
debate
or they're at least afraid of how he'll
do it the next debate because now we're
being told by the left
that debates themselves are a quote
threat
to black life threat to black life
that is some hysterical
stuff i don't even know what that could
mean you know what else i don't know i
don't know
how to fix my own car i don't know it
very well but
luckily rock auto makes the process much
much easier rockauto.com is a family
business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably
low and the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts rockauto.com catalog
is unique remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle
and choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer
they have a great selection they have
reliably low prices and my favorite part
of it
even i can understand the catalog and
then you don't need to go into the brick
and mortar and then
they don't have your part and then they
go online probably to rockauto.com
order it charge you twice as much you
don't have to do any of that go to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck write knowles know w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about xbox so
that they
know that we sent you that is
rockauto.com makes
the process so easy that even i can do
it
debates themselves we are now told are a
quote
threat to black life this is from
melissa harris perry
she had a show on msnbc she's been a
prominent left-winger for some time
she was responding to someone who said
if the presidential debates are just
going to give trump a platform to
mobilize white supremacists
cancel them cancel the white
supremacists i guess they're talking
about
the proud boys but as we just said look
the proud boys they might be no good
terrible rotten dirty
horrible people i don't know i do i
don't know anything about the proud boys
but here's what i do know by definition
they can't be white supremacists
right because like their leader
is not a white guy and a lot of their
members are not white guys
and they explicitly condemn racism and
white supremacy so
at least i know that so i know that
tweet is a lie and then melissa
harris-perry responding says
yes cancel them the debates are now a
danger to public safety and a threat
to black life cancel the debates
this is what you hear a lot now from the
left they say
it's not that i need to shut you up
because i can't
bear to hear some hard truth that you're
saying
or i can't bear to refute some lie that
you're saying
they're saying your speech is a threat
to my life
it makes me unsafe i need i need a safe
space that's where safe space comes from
how is the debate a threat to anybody's
life well because it's going to gin up
violence right president
trump's ginning up white supremacist
violence except all the violence of the
last six months has been from the left
all of it
all of it all of it look around the
different cities
minneapolis portland new york
dc chicago always chicago
los angeles every all over the place
that's not right wing violence it's not
conservative violence
it's not white supremacist violence it's
not
it's not any of that it's all leftist
it's all these left anarchists who are
being encouraged by the democratic party
when joe biden comes out and says we
can't take four more years of this he's
saying vote for trump
don't elect me and we're going to burn
your country to the ground for another
four years
that is a threat that is a threat maybe
maybe that's the issue maybe
maybe melissa harris-perry is worried
that joe biden is ginning up his
base which is actually committing the
violence
all i know is that this white
supremacist thing this idea
that america is a white supremacist
country is a bizarre fantasy
it's like a national fetish it's so
weird and it's so obviously contrary to
reality
we we have one law in this country that
does discriminate on the basis of race
that law is called
affirmative action that discriminates on
the basis of race but it gives an
advantage
to people who are black or who are
hispanic and it gives a disadvantage to
people who are white or asian
most notably in the college application
process which is why asian students have
been suing
harvard and yale this is why the
department of justice is
investigating places such as yale for
this very matter
that's not white supremacy that's the
opposite white supremacy
show me the white supremacist law point
to it in the books where is it
doesn't exist college campuses are
probably
the craziest place for this sort of
thing
and things just got even crazier there
is
a a college professor a guy named
matthew j
mayhew who just wrote a piece
about how he likes college football
it's called why america needs college
football brings us together
distracts us you know we can we can
fight over silly things like football
teams
and we can all just sit down maybe grill
up some steaks
crack a cold one be americans again
right well he now has to apologize for
that
apparently that was white supremacist if
college football is white supremacist
who knew apparently it is
from inside higher ed matthew j mayhew
apologizes for an article that he
recently wrote
for inside higher ed and describes
beginning a long process of
anti-racist learning anti-anti-racist by
the way
is the scariest orwellian term that has
been invented since anti-fascist
because obviously it doesn't mean what
it pretends to mean it means
the opposite america does it this is
what he writes
america doesn't need college football i
was wrong and even worse i was
uninformed
ignorant and harm-inducing i am sorry
for the hurt sadness frustration fatigue
exhaustion and pain this article has
caused anyone but specifically black
students in the higher education
community and beyond
i'm struggling to find the words to
communicate the deep ache
for the damage i have done i don't want
to write anything that further deepens
the pain experienced by my ignorance
related to black male athletes in the
black community all capital b by the way
at any time but especially in light of
the national racial unrest
unrest that's another orwellian term
isn't it unrest you mean violence
you mean blm violence burning down
cities yeah i also don't want to write
anything that suggests that anti-racist
learning is quick or easy
no it it ain't quick or easy man they're
going to torture you until you
until you finish it and figure it out uh
blah blah blah blah blah
now here's my favorite line i learned
that black men putting their bodies on
the line for my enjoyment
see this is the new thing because
they're all materialists so it's all
about black bodies not black people they
don't have souls according to the left
they just have bodies and
anytime you have a body it's and it's
used in sports for instance
that's evil because there could be
violence to the bodies
i learned that black men putting their
bodies on the line for my enjoyment is
inspired and maintained by my uninformed
and disconnected whiteness and as
written in my previous article
positions student athletes as white
property white lowercase w
b black capital b white lowercase w this
is obviously really pathetic really
racist
really condescending and really really
wrong
stuff all because some
wimp weirdo creep
professor made the completely
obvious statement that college football
is
fun he expressed his preference for
college football you want to see how
crazy this national mania over white
supremacy has become
governor gavin newsom governor patrick
bateman over here in california
just signed legislation yesterday that
will establish a nine-member state task
force
to study slavery and explore the
potential avenues
for reparations for black people
the law does not say should we or should
we not
have reparations take money from some
people and give them
to black people today some of whose
ancestors were slaves maybe
many of whose ancestors were not slaves
some of whom descended from slave owners
like kamala harris or barack obama
it's not should they or shouldn't they
it's how much
and to whom reparations for slavery in
california
i don't know how many of you are history
buffs a lot of people are missing the
greatest irony of this california
reparations bill look the reparations
argument is completely ridiculous
but a lot of people are missing the
biggest irony here
california was a free state
was not a slave state was a free state
actually the entrance of california into
the union
was one of the causes of the civil war
california entering the union the
compromise of 1850
is a moment where the united states is
grappling with the
the fact that slavery is untenable
because you're always in this 10
situation
where you have to introduce a state a
slave state and a free state both at the
same time
you can't have these two things running
forever and ever ultimately then
by the end of that decade you have the
civil war
which as far as i can tell was pretty
good reparations for slavery
national tearing apart 700
000 people americans dead grappling with
this
issue grappling with this problem and
then obviously plenty
of racially discriminatory laws that
came up jim crow
right that that actually were racially
discriminatory
on behalf of whites in certain areas
and then after to rectify that you had
laws that tried to
and this is sandra day o'connor
describes it this way you had to
discriminate back on the other side to
rectify that but now
all of that none of that all of that
including the civil war means absolutely
nothing
because california is going to take
money from some people and give it to
other people how are you going to do
that let me ex let me just give you
one of the ironies of history that is
that shows how crazy this reparations
issue is
the first officially recognized
slave owner of an arbitrarily declared
slave for life
a guy who would be declared sort of the
first slave owner
in the system that became american
slavery
was a black guy he was a black angolan
named anthony johnson
his slave who court just declared you're
slave for life not because you committed
a crime not for some offense not for
debt
just you're just a slave now you're his
property for life
john casor another black guy
do the descendants of anthony johnson
the slave owner
do they get reparations because of the
color of their skin
what about the descendants of john kaser
do they
can they go back to the descendants of
anthony johnson and say give me money
because
your great great granddaddy own my great
great granddaddy
or is it going to just be based on race
if it's based on race that's going to be
pretty weird
because there's an irony when barack
obama became the first black president
that he wasn't descended
from any american slaves right his
father is from kenya
he was actually descended from a slave
owner on the white side of his family
is barack obama entitled to reparations
does barack obama need reparations it
seems like he's doing pretty good
this is not to say that there isn't
historical injustice
it's actually to say the opposite
there's always historical injustice
there's injustice right now give you one
example we're killing a million babies a
year
obviously they won't have ancestors to
receive reparations
would that they did wouldn't that be so
wonderful
the the problem here is not a
representation of historical injustice
the problem is a complete
misunderstanding of of what the world is
right
this is a fallen world it's not
perfectable
you can't you cannot you actually cannot
make up
for every injustice in history couldn't
couldn't possibly be done
there is there is a way to get out of
this cycle
the way to get out of this cycle this is
going to be the most shocking thing of
all
is christianity because the son of god
comes down to earth and dies for your
sins
and gives you redemption that is the
whole point of christianity
is to solve this problem that american
leftists western leftists now
have rejected right they've totally
rejected that religion and so
all they have is the injustice all they
have is the sin
the original sin as we would call the
people call slavery the original sin
i call originals in the original sin but
all you have is that right all you have
is this sense that we are fallen we are
broken this world is not perfectable but
when you get rid of the christianity
from the civilization
there's no redemption there's no way out
there's just
burning the whole damn thing to the
ground and that is at bottom the
philosophical issue
and the theological issue and the
anthropological issue that we've been
struggling with
for not just the past six months but
since since our sense of religion has
ebbed
from our society and it's not going to
get better until we recover that
a reparations bill isn't going to do a
damn
thing now the good news i do have some
good news here even as the left has
totally rejected redemption
i do have some good news people are
beginning to turn
on the left minnesota right now there
was a poll
the mpr news star tribune k-a-r-e-11
minnesota poll was just released on
saturday
about views on black lives matter and a
validly marxist organization
that exacerbates this very issue we've
just been talking about
people were asked do you have a
favorable or unfavorable opinion of the
black lives matter movement
46 percent of poll respondents said
they have an unfavorable view compared
to 42 percent who say favorable
more people dislike the blm movement now
than like it i wonder why it turns out
when you burn down people's cities
they don't like you very much they don't
think that's particularly productive
doesn't help anybody obviously
blm says we need to defund the police
four out of five black voters say we
we should not defund the police there's
a chasm opening up here
between what the ideologues think people
should want and what people
actually want one number one statistic
has me a little worried though
i like those statistics i like that the
hispanic vote
uh viewers of telemundo thought trump
won the debate i like
that more people in many minneapolis and
minnesota are turning against blm than
support blm
but there's a number that worries me
according to deadline the debate the
other night drew just 27.3
million viewers which is a 36 drop
from 2016. why does this worry me this
worries me because
i fear that there will not be the same
enthusiasm to go out there and beat joe
biden as there was to beat hillary
clinton people tuned in in 2016
because hillary clinton is so so
so unlikable she is a liar
she's a cheat she's a crook
she's just people have not liked this
woman for a very long ever since she
tried to destroy her health care system
the first time
there were bumper stickers in the 90s
said impeach clinton and her husband
remember that they don't feel that way
about joe biden
joe biden is a joke he's a punchline
he's a doofus
he's a plagiarist he's a liar he's a
cynic sure
but he's just much much more likable
and if people are not willing to tune in
to watch trump smack down biden right
and the way they were willing to smack
down hillary
they might not be willing to go show up
and by the way we're still litigating
the 2016 election this hasn't ended this
is all
just one long process here the democrats
still haven't accepted the results of
the 2016 election
they cheated the administration spied on
president trump's campaign
and then those bureaucrats those
holdovers those democrats
tried to launch a coup to overturn the
election
and a lot of this came down to james
comey the former fbi director who
our pal senator ted cruz absolutely
slammed on the hill yesterday this
investigation of the president was
corrupt
the fbi and the department of justice
were politicized and weaponized
and in my opinion there are only two
possibilities
that you were deliberately corrupt or
woefully incompetent
and i don't believe you were incompetent
this has done severe damage to the
professionals and the honorable men and
women at the fbi
because law enforcement should not be
used as a political weapon
and that is the legacy you've left
so which is it is jim comey incompetent
or corrupt
obviously obviously it's the latter jim
comey
for all of his many flaws does not
appear to be a stupid man
it is not possible that the
the amount of lies the amount of
cover-ups the amount of illegal activity
that took place
during and around the 2016 election
just whoopsie days he passed without his
notice that is not
credible you saw during the debate
president trump said we're going to get
to the bottom of what happened and by
the way
by the way joe you signed off on a lot
of those
activities and you can see joe biden he
didn't know how to respond to that he
kind of
he didn't know how to respond to a lot
of things but he didn't get one of his
barbs and he just
kind of let that one go we will be
speaking to senator ted cruz you know i
speak to senator ted cruz a lot because
we have the show together verdict
but i had senator cruz come over to my
channel we filmed an interview
it will be available on the michael
knowles show youtube channel because i
look i didn't want to talk about all
that you know really important stuff
about whatever the
supreme court the constitution whatever
i had something else that i needed the
senator to talk to me about which is
i needed him to teach me how to write a
book with words you know i'm writing a
book with words right now
but it's much more difficult than
writing a book without words so the
senator came over gave me a couple
lessons head on over to the youtube
channel check it out
in the meantime get the senator's book
one vote away how a single supreme court
seat can change
history i gotta tell you my my big
uh plug for this book is that most
politician books are incredibly stupid
and they're all like that's like the
courage to be the courage
to have courage the leadership of
leading
politicians and leading and being a
leader and they're all just dumb and
they didn't even write it themselves
usually they didn't have it they didn't
even read it themselves and they're just
not worth reading the senator's book
very much worth reading i do know that
he did this book
i know it because these are his stories
they're his stories from consequential
supreme court cases
that hinged on one single vote you'll
actually leave learning something so i'm
really enjoying it
reading it right now also just another
little plug a new pro-life movie is
coming out called
the order of rights starring my producer
ben davies that's right
ben davies and emma l roberts it's gonna
be released tomorrow october 2nd on
streaming platforms so go on and check
that out
as well we'll be right back with the
mailbag
let's get into it from jeremy
dear fiery yet mostly peaceful catholic
cult member and podcaster
knowles in whom i should note the dogma
lives loudly
i have a question about the i paid more
taxes than trump
stickers why would leftists be proud of
this using their own arguments the
stickers should read i paid more taxes
to a system of white supremacy and
minority oppression
than trump is there a fault in my logic
on this thanks p.s
reclaiming my time yeah it's the same
issue that you hear from
from the left on guns for instance they
say
trump is a nazi so give the government
all your guns
well hold on trump trump is the head of
the government
and trump is a nazi so you're telling me
to give all my guns to nazis
doesn't matter because they don't pay
attention to their logic and
at a base level they don't
believe in logic i'm not saying that oh
they're dumb oh they they don't have
facts and logic at their side i'm
actually saying something
a little more radical than that they
don't have
faith in logic they think that logic and
they've said this recently in
in popular pamphlets that have gone out
they think logic
is a social construct that was invented
by human beings
to to prop up white supremacy and
patriarchy
they'll say that they'll say reason
logic objective truth
these are terms that are about white
supremacy and so
obviously if they don't have any faith
in logic they can make an argument but
then they'll make the opposite argument
out of the other side of their mouth and
it doesn't matter
to them because it's all just fake
anyway
this is a very simple example of
sophistry when you're like he's a he's a
sophist he's a usually using a sophistry
that's what it is where
it's all about the rhetoric it's all
about the sound
of the argument but and the emotion and
the passion but it's not about the logic
of the argument itself because
there is none from andrew hey michael it
came to mind that the government having
marriage
whether it be gay or straight is against
the first amendment
freedom of religion being that marriage
is a religious institution
this should be should have to be
something for the people on their own to
have to sort out
not something the government even has a
right to intervene in curious what your
thoughts are on this
am i misreading this thanks love your
show and all you do you are
in fact misreading this murder
is prohibited by the ten commandments
right murder that's a religious
statement that murder is evil thou shalt
not
commit murder that's a religious
statement it's a moral claim
so therefore the government has no
business in murder laws right
uh wrong uh you shall not steal
that's another religious claim so the
government has no
right right you shall not covet your
neighbor's ox
that's also a religious claim i don't
know that we have laws against coveting
one's neighbor's ox but
perhaps we should all laws
are moral laws i think what you're
you're kind of getting to this very
take your hands off kind of approach to
government kind of a libertarian
approach maybe
even though there's a lot of problems
with libertarianism but
it's a hands-off hey you know um i don't
i i don't want to be willing to make any
claims about
substantive claims about the good
because we can never know the good so
i'm just going to back off
and that doesn't work because all laws
necessarily are moral laws and
when you get to the extreme of
libertarians they basically say it's all
just about consent
right so basically marriage is just a
contract right so as long as you enforce
contract lots of fine or
or business right no it's just about
consent but but none of us
actually believes that right if i for
instance
let's say i'm going to start a business
i'm going to start uh the
a huge prostitution ring all right and i
contract with people right it's all
consenting adults
and i start a huge prostitution ring
that would still be illegal
let me take it one step further i start
a huge prostitution ring and
i put it next to your home in the
suburbs
right the zoning laws forget about the
zoning laws i'm
this is my consent government has no
right to come in
and stop me from doing that because i've
consented to it
and your idea that there needs to be
some separate space for residential
living that's outside of the commercial
world your idea
most importantly that there shouldn't be
prostitution rings in your name but
that's a religious idea
that gets down to your weird religious
hang-ups about sex and stuff right so
anyway you government has no right to of
course not and by the way the mayor
the marriage issue there are even some
quote unquote conservatives who say
government should get out of marriage
not possible because marriage is a
religious institution i guess sometimes
but it's primarily a political
institution actually
marriage predates christianity marriage
predates
there are plenty of marriages that
happen outside of a religious sphere
it's a political institution
it's actually the bedrock political
institution so the debate over
same-sex marriage as it became called
was not a debate over who should have
rights
it was nev at least if we're being
honest about it it's not a debate over
who who should have rights the debate
was over what is marriage
and for all of human history the
marriage
the term marriage has had at its essence
sexual difference husbands and wives
then like 10 years ago it was suggested
that we redefine that pretty radically
to say sexual difference has
nothing to do with marriage but for some
reason monogamy still has to do with
marriage
i don't know why how come so if we can
redefine it so radically
to take out the sexual difference aspect
why does it have to be monogamous
right if one man loves three women that
certainly has much more historical
precedent
than taking out the sexual difference
piece so it's i think it's disingenuous
obviously the state has a great interest
in
children in propagating the next
generation regulating that
child abuse all these sorts of things
you know there is a role for the
child protective services to come in
state has a role in all of that
and if our politics is to have any
meaning at all
it must be able to discuss and establish
definition
for the bedrock political institution
but we never got to have that debate
because the left just
begged the question the life just
assumed its own conclusion namely that
marriage is
the monogamous union of any two people
who love each other
for a lot of history love was not the
central consideration in marriage
at least not romantic love in the way
that we think of it now okay but they
just assumed they said okay that's it
and so sexual difference goes out the
window and now we've assumed our own
conclusion
and therefore we've proved it so we're
gonna do it we never had that debate and
sadly as our as our national uh
presidential debate showed us the other
night
we might not be serious enough anymore
in this country
to have real debates so maybe the left
was right from danny hey michael
i consider myself a recovering leftist i
was converted to conservatism
by my wonderful husband when you often
describe the crazy purple-haired
feminist
there's me oh hey i'm glad we got a
former
purple-haired feminist to watch the show
i recently posted something about
brianna taylor's case
on social media and my old college
roommate who i haven't seen in years
flat out called me a racist
yeah they say that's what they do they
do that a lot all because we didn't
agree
my position to you is in two parts how
do you handle personal vitriol from
those you may have once considered
friends
and how does it end for america came for
ben stayed for knowles
this is a fallen world evil happens uh
going back to
uh what we were discussing earlier with
regard to the only
possibility of redemption uh christ
comes into the world
and he doesn't say hey i'm the way in
the truth and the life and when you
proclaim me and when you are with me
then everybody will be really nice to
you he doesn't
does not say that yeah you'll you'll
you'll be treated so well in this world
he who thrives in this world for my sake
will
keep thriving no doesn't say all of that
people don't like the truth right
you want the truth you can't handle the
truth so
very often people would rather live in
darkness and shadows
and not be in the light and not talk
about the truth and this is just baked
into it
look at what they did to jesus right
just not to put too fine a point on it
but that that actually is an example for
us
that that is what pick up your cross
pick up your cross and bear it right
so obviously we're just talking about a
very narrow example here which is over
some political debates
but it gets to a broader example which
is that very often when you proclaim the
truth you will be persecuted for it
because it's a fallen world that's the
cost of it that's the cost of
preferring the truth to lies that's the
cost of having courage
to being a coward that's the cost of the
virtues
i think the benefits of those virtues
certainly outweigh the costs it's a it's
a good investment in the long run but
in the short run your friends or your
former friends are going to say all
sorts of nasty horrible things about you
that's just the way it is i'll give you
an example of this i
my first political campaign i ever
worked on was for a friend of mine she
was running for congress in my district
i was 18 or 19 so freshman
or sophomore in college in my hometown
i had been the golden boy my whole life
you know top of the class class
president uh
always all the parents were very nice to
me and everything
and uh very sort of i don't know i was
very well liked
and the minute that i started working
for a republican
totally mainstream republican candidate
just as an intern on a campaign
half the town called me all sorts of
horrible things
so wait a second two weeks ago you were
saying i was a nice guy well yeah but
now you're a republican so
sorry sorry you're a terrible racist
awful vicious terrible no good person
comes with the territory it comes with
the territory and
dick cheney had a point on this he was
asked does it bother you the people call
you darth vader and he said
when i was secretary of defense i was
the most popular man in the country 90
plus percent approval rating
when i was vice president i was one of
the least popular men in the country
if i wanted to be popular i would have
been a movie star sometimes it's more
important to be successful than to be
popular
from brian it's clear at this point that
we are two nations at what point do we
split
is it peaceful do we try to preserve the
union wouldn't splitting be better for
us
we could live the way we want to without
having to deal with the left
no we should not split no splitting is
not better
you can tell i'm catholic in this answer
because i don't think divorce
is acceptable divorce is never
acceptable
now sometimes when there is a threat of
say bodily harm or something like that
a separation is important
you need to stay apart might even be
required but a divorce no
so i think yes there are some ways that
we should lay off each other here in the
united states i think there's some ways
that there might be should be a little
bit more separation perhaps
you're actually seeing this happen which
is conservatives are going to red states
and
and leftists are going to bluer states
but a divorce no first of all it's
completely unworkable
right how is it go what's going to
happen the coasts are going to break off
and then the middle of the country is
going to stay so we're not going to have
any
any any seaports or anything we're not
going to let that happen
what certain cities are going but what
about the people in those cities it's
not going to work
national divorces like
familial divorces are evil evil things
and
and bad things happen when when that
that occurs so i i wouldn't support that
just like i wouldn't support throwing my
hands up in a marriage
don't do it do not do it sometimes it
happens because again fallen world right
so
i'm not saying that that won't happen
but but i certainly wouldn't cheer it on
from aruna dear dr coffey
most professional of daily wire
podcasters my employer is hosting a live
virtual
session on anti-racism with none other
than dr ibrahim
kendi this session is optional and to
someone who is morally opposed to racism
i'm considering by the way i'm just
gonna pause there everybody's opposed to
racism racism right racism what does
that mean
to uh to judge unjustly
on the basis of race uh which is an
offense to human
dignity right and and human solidarity
because
all men are made in the image of god so
yes everybody opposes that it's like i
don't even want to say that anymore that
i'm opposed to it because it gives them
the premise
that there are all these people who are
super duper racist
i guess the left is but but the right
not so very
very few people very few people i'm
considering not attending this
session since i wouldn't want anyone to
misconstrue my presence for ascent to dr
kindy's
racist philosophy on the other hand i do
want to be informed about what my
co-workers are being taught by this man
and since no one is compelling me to
attend i'm somewhat more willing to give
the other side a fair hearing
should i go to this thing or should i
spend the hour doing what my employer
actually pays me to do
it will be a waste of your time in the
sense that that man dr candy has nothing
but
poison to spew and he's just a complete
huckster he's a pseudo
academic a pseudo scholar he's a con
artist who is
milking companies such as yours for
money
by selling racial grievance based on
lies but i probably would still go
especially if it weren't
compulsory because i want the
information and i want to know how to
refute it so yeah i would say maybe go
see if you can bear it speaking of
barrett last question from julia hey
michael love the show are you at all
concerned
that justice barrett will turn out to be
a more moderate judge and fall short of
a lot of conservatives expectations
or do you think she'll be like scalia
and thomas thanks no way to predict the
future and she hasn't been on the bench
that long so i don't know
but here's what i do know the markers
are good she's at least
written extensively about her views and
her views seem pretty solid
she clerked for scalia that's a good
sign apparently scalia really liked her
that's a good sign
she's super duper catholic so she is
living her faith
it's conservative faith right just by
definition
that's a good thing like all of that she
seems
judicious that's that's a good thing
and what's the alternative we're not
living in a world where i just get to
pick any justice i want there's one
justice up one justice could possibly be
confirmed here
that's judge barrett the alternative is
let the dems have the court or leave it
open which which will exacerbate the
constitutional crisis that i suspect
we're already in
so i'm all in for barrett i don't i
don't know i'm totally saying right now
we can't know
the future but there's no other option
three cheers for acb all right that's
our show
i will see you on monday i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton